よす地球人の子よ
不意に
常に我々が待っていた前節のオペアンプが販売された
ん
こちらフェアグェスば限定販売品分エラー
すごいだろうそうこれはとてもすごいこと
金浦伊豆ねクソ婆がコンビニに帰るなんて
をそれを信じられざるで私はこの限定販売という言葉で言われるねーご覧の通り
ティップウィニペグをキャットなってしまったあっはぁ
ださぁ者将棋でこんな[ __ ]口の中には人分が入っているそうだ
今思ったら
[音楽]
これ金になるんじゃねそういうことだいいかお前らよく聞け金を約様にかけてくるのは
ちょっともったいない気もしてしまう
まずはそれが美味しいからいいみたいなのはあるかもしれんが俺の得た行くとそういう
ことじゃないんだ
いい頑張ら床メロそのペア付の中に金粉が入ってるって事は
そうだそういうことだとりあえずひと袋にどれぐらい金分が入ってるか見てみよう話は
そこからどうぞ
しれないが中身はけっこう普通だがお
すくねまあまあおよそそんだけをしていた少ないんだよ
さすがに少ないんですけど一応これこれぐらい入ってますことですよこの量ですね
まつげが入っておりますね金がこれもどう見てもねそこでだ
そこでなお前らよく考えろペヤング食べて品分だけをサルベージすると白そうすると
これが楽 kuro て書いてた告げに来取るような100円食らったらそれの憲法の
ように
それとどうなるかはい時で表の客は勤勉500買ったので開けると取れるわけですよ
こうやってこの金粉は100袋分集めて売ろうと思いますたぶんこれに限定販売って
ことはやっぱりたくさん売れないわけですよたくさん売れないでちょっと理由があって
タブンネ字を取れるんですよね金で高価なものなんで多分これだけ運作るとなんかなん
かになるんでそれ100袋
不ウルトただそこそこの管理になる果たして金9分ぐらい入っているのかというとも気
になったんでお金ペンも全部開封してこの金箔だけサルベージしていこうと思います
そして売ります果たして9になるのでしょうか
vip のせっかく発売されて食べないともったいないんで人はもだけ食べてみ
ましょう
金入れる思ったね
なんやもう絶えないかどうかわからんけどさを入れます
すごいぞキラキラしてるさーああああ抱きます
さすがにこのような金だと味は変わらないですねただ普通にペアごとして大一です愛着
早速こちらの
whipping の in 分だけ取り除いてあったぞめていくことをなぜは行こう
かもいっぱい入って受けてまず罰金分ところを作るだけでとりあえず取り巻くいます8
位
[音楽]
あれ代々者イベっほっ
あげましたチェーン席でわかったなあー
リーマス
[音楽]
ええええええ
th
大風おおおおっ待っていません
本当に内側の壁ます
えっあっはーんセキュンっ
汚れずいぶんすぎでまず見つからんという
まあぽくなったり友達とれる理由であることだ
それじゃないと見落としてるねー
うっ
すごいすごい発見父兄フクロウな形が全く違うのがありましたなんだろうこれ
何よりはバラバラ雪はれたこれ
[音楽]
巨大はハードもおかしくないぞ
俳優で結構なくなってきましたが待ってきたんですけどもうあのー疲れました
内職ゲーすぎてちょっと飽きてきたけどまあまあ頑張ります
[音楽]
持った
ええええええ
tan tan
ねただ系の夕べボーン
かき集め
アシモを探しに行くのさ
ポケットとボイン染め遠い遠いまあ俺
ネオンんウイン夢をっていう本でああああ
で親欧
[音楽]
もう夏とさんですマジできつかったんですねまあ余裕ですけど同じどうぞやってると
ちょっと苦しいとがゆえ
[音楽]
ランドレス
ええええええ
はい学校金箔作兵衛地管理としましたはい時で集まったんですけども k っこで多い
か分からない出す見ないとちょっと何とも言えないんですけどもご覧くださいまあ結構
な量の緊迫が使ったと思いますそれ今から少なかったしていきましょう愛的で鍵盤が
全部でのということで早速これをビンに移していきましょう
まぁこれぐらいの量であれば好みも末端日
ua いますすいません嘘ですここに入れますこっちの方がわかりやすいと思うので
早速緊迫のも入れていきましょう
もうなるべく空亡無駄にしたくないんじゃ頑張っていきます
[音楽]
一応わー
これ8-れるのはなってるとわかる
[音楽]
すごいなこれ何かわかんないしてみた感じ元によってすごい両案にバラつきがある気が
しますはかでそう見えるだけが欲しいんですけど全部同じくらいなんだろうなぁどれ
くらい入ってるんだろ
ni
re re
いき吹きかけたら吹っ飛んできたのでこれでもうちょい
ん
何体の地道な作業だマジできつい手汗がすごい椎名
なんかてがテカテカしてるしよ立っ
あーフォア
ないという理由だよなぁ当て多いのかな
わかんない市近辺の価値がわかんないんですけどもズベズダ金プリペアぐ100個分の
切符がこちらになります
有病カードと今日よりと生んだもんですねいやー
[音楽]
なんともいえんなんとーやんアナといえなんてどういう
なんとヘイなんと立ち上げ猫のこれぐらいの量の統計ペンサーズが買い取ってくれるの
かどうかがわかんないんですけど早速ちょっと買ってもらえないかとかと聞いてみよう
と思います
[音楽]
あっ強性とちょっと近的なものを売りたいんですけど
残し福岡が入っていただきたいんですけどあの
金箔を売りたいんですけど
[拍手]
そうですねこうパラパラっといろいろ滝厚みだというか
あえて涼子ともうねこれよそうですねはい
いいましたわん
ご確認いたしますのでお電話少々このままに3分明けだがてくださいはいありがとう
ございます
あるぞあるぞこれこれ金ピン2ペアんが250円なんですよ f 2のピンクが
170円なんねー
多分緊縛だけで80やすくね87とか
ちょっと不安になってきましたねまあとりあえず売れるが10日だけ聞いてみましょう
[音楽]
はいっ
箱のほうがですねはいここでお買取対象外となっておりますのでいた
わかりましたありがとうございますはい
はい
お願いしますか
yeah
確認をさせていただいたんですけれども入った金盗んでござるだったゲイジャパン場外
のを持ちなも
になっておりませ
わかりましたすいませんありがとうございます aa とんでもないですはい失礼致し
ます
バッハ
はいというわけでちょっといろいろセラべたりしたんですけども
金粉ってなんか買取がほぼ方ないっていうかもう武者はないぐらいらしいですなんだっ
けがなんか純度が低いのかな
金粉は売れないみたいです
ほほ
をほぼ黒
だああああ
ああああああああ
いいいいいい
rar
ni
普通
[音楽]
me
me あった